so the impression I'm getting is that
the feelings about this season of Picard
have been a little bit mixed among Star
Trek fans so if you don't like what I
have to say
oh you'll set your comments to stun and
not kill I have been going really lame
with the opening jokes lately okay
anyways I have now finished the first
season of Star Trek Picard and I up to
this point I've talked about to some
degree episodes 1 through 6 so I am
gonna be talking about the last four I'm
probably gonna be mostly talking about
the finale so I'm guess that's your
spoiler warning III will touch on some
of the stuff that happen up that but
there'll also be a lot of my thoughts
about the thing overall as it exists as
a complete season now if you want my
broad thoughts before I start getting
into any things that will qualify as
spoilers I liked more than I didn't like
and even the things that like I didn't
love I didn't hate they just sort of
left me be like hmm is that the best
wait did we you know sort of thing
nothing made me angry but again to
remind people my fan relationship with
Star Trek is much more ancillary than
say my fan relationship with Star Wars
or Marvel or Doctor Who I enjoy Star
Trek I grew up with Star Trek I've never
been a deep cut fan of it and there's
actually aside from the movies there's
no segment of Star Trek that I have
encyclopedia encyclopedic knowledge of
there's no series of Star Trek that I've
seen every episode of so if you think
that invalidates my opinion that's a
weird thing to think but if that
explains the discrepancy between what I
thought of this and what you thought of
it if you happen to be a bigger fan of a
much bigger swath of Star Trek that
might account for it let's go with that
so for the most part I still enjoyed
this and I had been liking it up to this
point
I like the general feel of it I think it
does a good job of moving things forward
for the Star Trek time line which it's
frigging needed to do forever and
anchoring it on Picard as a character
worked very well because Patrick Stewart
did an excellent job of slipping into
this and even though this story overall
is a bit darker and a bit nastier than I
would personally usually want out of a
Star Trek story
it still works for me because it's
dealing with kind of a nasty segment and
a nasty time but I don't think it does
what say like Logan did and this is not
a knock on Logan I actually think
Logan's a great film but Logan took the
characters that we knew and took those
characters and broke them and put them
in an awful world I don't feel like Star
Trek Picard breaks the characters that
we know it presents them in a way that
feel that is either consistent with what
we've seen from them in the past or
feels like a pretty natural progression
at least as far as I understand these
characters puts them in a situation that
is worse and darker but it doesn't it
doesn't break them as characters unlike
having Professor X swear and Logan
Picard is you know he's still Picard you
still identify ably Picard and that
works very well for me is there swearing
in this yes is all it does all of it
work
no like the the Admiral or the commander
or whatever she is who swears that
Picard her I buy cuz that of like that's
just who you are as a person but like
when other characters would swear it
would throw me off it didn't always feel
like it belonged there so sometimes that
was a little weird but overall I did
enjoy this not all of the characters are
great and some of them by the time it
was done I didn't know what to think or
feel about them so so let's go through
the cast aside from Picard who I think
is done very well ríos duggan I like and
I also like all of the different
holographic interfaces for the different
functions of the ship but I like how
they're all slightly different in
personnel
some even have different accents I had a
lot of fun with him like honestly and
I'm not saying they should actually do
this but I would totally watch a
spin-off that was just him and that ship
arguing with the Holograms like that's
the series I would watch that I'd have
fun with that Rafi was fine
I don't know exactly what it was she
brought functionally to the story though
I she's not a dish she's not a
distraction she doesn't she doesn't take
anything away so there's no harm in
having her there but I don't really know
if I can nail down what she was intended
to bring to the to the proceedings she
seemed to be the an occasional
exposition dump and I guess she kind of
helped with some of the logistics in the
first half but then the question becomes
well why she's still here after that and
again I'm not saying that they should
have ditched her cuz it's not like
having her around is a bad thing but I
feel like they didn't really know what
to do with her after a certain point but
she was just still there and again not a
problem just a little bit of a if you
were going to keep her around could you
have found more use for her other than
just basically being the additional
member of this plan that could have
happened without her which seemed to be
what kept going on with her over and
over and over again so Elmore he just
never clicked for me like conceptually I
think he's a cool idea but it really
does feel to me like they wanted to
somehow put Legolas in Star Trek and
then they just tried to reverse engineer
how do we do that and he just doesn't
really click for me I don't know if it's
because he feels out of place as a
characterization or if it's just because
the performance was wooden I don't know
he just never really worked for me
unlike with Rafi I get why he's there I
get his utility to the narrative but I
also didn't enjoy his present
as much so you gotta have a nice little
contrast going on there where's Ruffy I
enjoyed her presence but I'm not always
entirely sure why she was there
whereas LR I understood why he was there
but I didn't actually like him
so yeah bit of an issue there Agnes
Agnes is a character I am super
conflicted about because I feel like I
feel like the show couldn't or I have a
good nerve I just decided it wasn't
going to decide on its own how we were
supposed to feel about her it and the it
tries it what it tries to do is make her
kind of tragic in the sense of you know
she gets shared this vision that
convinces her that synthetic life is
cannot be allowed and she believes that
so wholeheartedly that she kills a
friend and lover because because he
might at some point recreate or maybe I
already has created synthetic life but
then she basically snaps out of it as
soon as she meets Sochi in person and I
think that's the component that doesn't
quite work for me because I will buy
that this vision you know projected via
mind meld was so immediate and visceral
and literally burned into her brain that
she did do something that under any
other circumstances she never would have
done and it broke her up to do it but
the ease of which she snaps out of it
just by meeting and starting to talk to
Shoji like I get what they were going
for Shoji basically reaffirmed all of
the things that she was passionate and
cared about before she was shown this
vision and so I do what they're trying
for but it's too easy there isn't enough
of an internal conflict from her and I
feel like the fact that she killed a man
is kind of brushed aside by the
narrative by the supporting cast and by
her and
saying she shouldn't have been granted
forgiveness for that but it felt like it
came too easy and then she had slipped
back into her slightly awkward charm a
little too soon for how much they broke
her as a character to have her repair as
apparently easily as they did that
didn't quite click I can see the
progression they were going for and it's
not a bad one the execution doesn't
quite land though and it really threw me
off when she kissed Rios like at the
very end of the last episode I was like
what I don't know if I just have
blinders on and had missed something but
I was like where the hell did that come
from that felt very unearned and not
necessarily like he came out of
absolutely nowhere but like I feel like
we jumped a bit there like that should
not be there quite yet No so do with
Sochi suffers from the problem that a
lot of characters like her suffer from
which is that she is as much a plot
device as she is a character in her own
right and a big part of her
characterization is figuring out who she
is which unfortunately as a result makes
her a bit of a blank slate which the
narrative needs her to be because she
needs to be malleable enough that she is
willing to trust Picard and go on this
journey and then we have to seriously be
able to believe that she would
effectively portray Picard in order to
bring about this thing that's gonna wipe
out all organic and non synthetic life
in the universe and she has to be
malleable enough for those leaves to
work and I think she is but that pretty
much always creates a character who is
not excessively compelling in and of
themselves because they have to have the
wiggle room to make those jumps which he
tends to make them a bit under
characterized I honestly felt that dodge
had a much stronger characterization and
only one episode than Shoji did across
the remaining what was it nine episodes
it's a little bit of Clara Oswald
syndrome if you're a Doctor Who fan this
whole thing we're like we get introduced
to alternate versions first that are way
better characterized and then we get the
quote-unquote real version the one we're
going to be stuck with for a while and
they seem undercooked and underdeveloped
and then they don't get to develop as
much because they're a plot point as
as a character if not more so I really
did get flashbacks to Clara with that so
again I understand why it happened for
the narrative for what they were going
to be doing with her but it does result
in a character that is difficult for me
to really latch on to the villains were
fine I mean let's be honest Star Trek as
a general rule is not known for its
villains there are a handful of really
good ones
the Borg collectively con but you know
by and large villains art have never
really been Star Trek strong suit at
least not individual villains collective
villains like the Klingons the Borg the
Romulans those can work but when they
try and make individuals strong villains
but just the franchise doesn't have a
great history on that they're not bad
the the bread the Romulan brother
insisted okay they work they function
that's about all I've got to say about
them seven of nine I had a lot of fun
with now to be fair I've seen very
little Voyager so I can't speak to
whether or not this character issues and
characterization makes sense and feels
earn from where she was when she left
off I can't speak to that I can just say
I had fun with her as far as the other
returning characters it was nice to see
will Will Riker and to see Deanna Troi
they that was nice and good but I gotta
say though I got a much bigger despite a
whole episode of them like kicking back
and Riker making
trying to make pizza or whatever I had a
much bigger grin on my face when he
shows at the end up at the end in the
captain's chair man he still looks good
in that uniform oh you know doing the
Commandant captain voice oh I'm so glad
they gave us that because I I didn't
dislike the scenes with Riker prior to
that but I was kind of like something's
missing and then he showed up again in
the uniform in the chair you know oh
give me an excuse I'm like that that's
what I was missing
oh that felt good
so the overall conflicts and sort of
resolution of it I have incredibly mixed
feelings about so I'll address one thing
first which i think is a nitpick and I
don't know if it's shared among the
community but I watched a Linkara
episode recently where he made reference
to it it obviously worked him but the
idea that a synthetic does a mind meld
I'm personally kind of okay with I'm
prepared to make that leap because we're
already accepting that they made
synthetics that can eat drink they get
tired sweat and all this other stuff
that we have with so gene dodge I'm like
is it that much more of a leap that if
they're already making synthetics that
can do all these things that synthetics
shouldn't be able to do that it's that
hard to believe they could also figure
out how to make the mind meld work I do
think that in episode it's a very hand
wave thing like oh she has studied
Vulcan like that's a lame sort of
stopgap explanation but conceptually I'm
okay with that
so where I'm conflicted is I think the
show really kind of set itself up to
stumble at the tail end by even finding
this civilization of synthetics because
it's one of those situations where
basically only one of two things were
going to happen they were going to turn
out to be a utopia or they were gonna
turn out to be a problem
and it kind of tries to have a boat have
it start to appear as a utopia and
become a problem
and so the it's already kind of muddling
a little bit and while that normally
that kind of progression of oh this play
seems great wait there's a problem
that's normally fine but the issue here
is by having them shift to becoming a
problem is it validates the villains
it makes the Romulans right and while
the this storyline doesn't validate the
Romulans tactics and their brutality it
does validate their motivations and that
was
pointing to me because initially they
had this notion of you know when when
that synth I forget our name now played
by the same actress who does so gee did
the mind meld like the preface that was
this is a vision that drives
non-synthetic CeMAT because they're not
meant to experience it let me see I'm
like oh it's gonna be recontextualized
except it wasn't really like we got
better details as to what it meant in
terms of them bringing in this other
dimensional somehow higher creation
level being of synthetic things to this
world but that just gave background to
and completely validated what the
Romulans always thought which was that
since that actually bring about the
destruction of everything else so it
didn't recontextualize it just totally
validated the villains which would also
make this really hard to re-watch
because as we are watching our heroes
escape the villains and triangle with
their leading things down the path that
is gonna get everybody killed and that's
kind of disappointing and kind of
frustrating so I didn't love that but at
the same time I do kind of like that the
ultimate resolution to that was Picard
being the diplomat not the tactician
that he finds a way to reach Soji and
the people who need to be reached and
stopped not by force of arms but by
being the example because that is very
Picard much more so than any combat
tactics he could have engaged in so I
don't like the nature of the conflict at
the climax I do however like the way
that they resolved it so that's why I'm
very torn on it the situation I don't
like I don't like how we get here and I
don't like the situation that we're in
but I do like the way that Picard
resolves it so I don't like it so much
that it suddenly justifies the situation
that we're in I still don't like it but
that was a good way to get us out of it
so you know again very mixed feelings
I will also say that at the end the the
whole so it basically is ex machina
resolution of well let's remove the
tension of this brain abnormality and
just give him a synthetic body oh but
don't worry it's effectively the exact
same as the body he had so he's not in
any way different he's not a superpower
anything we basically just gave him a
free life it's kind of cheap but again
conflicted because as cheap as that is
to the point that it actually kind of
makes the entire brain abnormality
subplot unnecessary for how easily it
was resolved with no lingering
consequences but at the same time I love
the scene with him and data I thought
that I thought that was the best scene
in the entire thing I thought that was
beautiful I really really loved that I
loved the way they connected the way
that data was able to explain to him you
know enough about himself that it gave
the card closure and it gave him
resolution and it was oh god brent
Spiner I mean I enjoyed him as yet
another soon like boy the data family
between lore and before and and union
song and now know what a weird cluster
and we keep finding more of them like
they gotta stop that but yeah I like
brent Spiner doing that he did it well
but seeing him be data again in the
makeup with the context with the jet
black hair oh he didn't miss a beat and
that was that was I always loved data
and that was a wonderful touching
heartfelt scene and I really really
adored it but again a bit like the
climax the thing that that scene is
nested in I don't really like but that
scene itself oh it was gold I absolutely
adored it and I really want to see what
will happen with another Steven Steven
C
because I feel like if you were gonna
pick up with Picard bringing some sort
of closure to the fact that data
sacrificed himself to save Picard was
something that had to be dealt with
because that was going to be the
lingering thing that never really got
addressed and Picard was someone who was
gonna carry that baggage and so what
we've effectively done is we've taken an
entire season to resolve his conflicted
guilt and his baggage and his trauma
over that should they have spent the
entire season doing only that I don't
know
character-wise that's basically what
they did but what it does is it frees
him and by proxy the show up to move
completely away from past baggage and go
somewhere new in a new season because I
do think this did need to get addressed
and to not address it would have been
kind of a disservice to not only data's
memory but also Picard as a character
but now that it's done I'm very excited
to see what would happen sort of
unshackled from past baggage so Picard
for the most part I liked it have some
very conflicted feelings about some of
the stuff that happened toward the end
but I'm absolutely excited for a second
season and want to see what will happen
so those are my thoughts on Star Trek
Picard did you watch all it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop them politely down in the
comments and let's talk about it there's
the usual stuff to do like share
subscribe share this around and all
those things hit the bell I guess not
everyone's getting notifications lately
plus I got a patreon all the usual stuff
but you don't have to do any of it
because end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time you care to join me in
my ready room this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]